To find classes,
we want to return to the registration
menu, then click Look Up Classes.
Then we'll select our term.
This will bring us to
a list of every subject
offered across the entire university.
Right now, the OMS program has classes
in two subjects, computer science and
computational science and engineering.
So we'll scroll down to those and
use Shift to select both.
Then we'll click Course Search and
we'll get a list of
all the courses in those subjects
that are offered in the semester.
You can then click View Sections to see
the status of the different sections
of that class.
We'll talk about this screen in a bit.
>> You might notice that this list
is actually pretty overwhelming.
You're seeing every class
offered on campus for
the entire semester as well
as the online classes.
We can make this a bit easier by
going and doing an advanced search.
Like before, we're going to
select Computational Science and
Engineering and
Computer Science as our subjects.
But then we're going to
scroll down to Campus and
select Online, and
then we'll do our search.
Then when I scroll down I'll see only
those courses offered in the online
campus or in the OMS program for
that semester.
This way you can focus
only on those classes for
which you can actually register.
So now let's talk about
actually registering.